اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه الساعه الجديده
والتي نخصص معظمها لتطورات الاحداث في
السودان وروسيا والبدايه بالعناوين
20 يوما على حرب السودان مصادر العربيه
تكشف عن استهداف جوي لتمركزات الدعم
السريع وسط الخرطوم
على واقع الحرب ولشمال دارفور يحذر من
كارثه انسانيه في مخيمات النازحين
وفي اخبارنا ايضا
بعد استهداف الكريم
يقول ان عمليه نابلس استهدفت منفذ هجوم
الاغوار الذي وقع الشهر الماضي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا تبادل الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع اليوم الاتهامات
بمهاجمه كل منهما الاخر رغم هدنه جديده
بدا سريانها اليوم جاء ذلك فيما افاد
مراسل العربي بان الاشتباكات التي تدور هي
الاعنف منذ بدء الصراع منتصف الشهر الماضي
من جانبه اعرب الامين العام المتحده عن
اسفه لاخفاق المنظمه في وقف الحرب حيث
تقوض المعارك المستمره جهود ترسيخ الهدنه
في هذه الاثناء مشاهدينا افاد مراسل
العربيه باندلاع معارك عنيفه في الخرطوم
حيث دوت الانفجارات منذ الصباح في محيط
القصر الجمهوري والقياده العامه للجيش
مراسل العربيه اكد ان الخرطوم تشهد
اشتباكات هي الاعلى منذ الاصطناع هذا
وتشهد العاصمه تحليقا للطيران الحربي
للجيش بشكل مكثف اما في ام درمان فتشهد
المدينه اطلاقا كثيفا لقاده في المدفعيه
بين الجانبين
هذا واظهر صور اقمار صناعيه حريقا في
مطايا خرطوم الدولي مع استمرار المواجهات
[موسيقى]
لم تتوقف الاتهامات المتبادله بخلق الهدنه
بين الجيش والدعم السريع وفي اخرها اتهم
بيان الدعم السريع قوات الجيش بشن قصف
عشوائي على عدد من مواقع تمركز قواتها
وبعض الاحياء السكنيه رغم الهدنه الجديده
التي بدا سريانها اليوم مؤكده على ان
القصف الذي شنه الجيش بالمدافع والطائرات
يشكل تجاوزا للاعراف والقوانين الدوليه في
المقابل اكد الجيش ان قوات الدعم السريع
حاولت الهجوم على قياده منطقه بحر
العسكريه واضاف الجيش السوداني ان قواته
دمرت عددا من العربات القتاليه التابعه
للدعم السريع واستلمت خمس عربات تم تركها
في ميدان المعركه
هذا واظهرت لقطات جويه تصاعد الدخان في
المواقع التي يعتقد ان قيادات لدعم السيده
تمركز فيها في الخرطوم بحري مقابل القصر
الجمهوري وتحديدا في حي حله حمد والمنطقه
الصناعيه وحي الاملاك
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا من درمان ينضموا الينا الصحفي
مقداد حسن اهلا بك مقداد وبدايه على ماذا
استفقدتم درمان هذا الصباح وكيف يبدو
المشهد فيها
نعم الساعات الاولى من هذا الصباح كانت
هنالك طلعات جويه وتحليق كثيف للطائرات في
سماء ام درمان وايضا كانت هنالك في ساعات
الاولى
للمضادات بكثافه من الارض وكذلك حتى هذه
اللحظه نشاهد تحليق الطائرات في سماء
اندرمان على ما يبدو ان سلاح الجو
السوداني يحاول ان يمسح المراكز التي
تتمركز فيها قوات الدعم السريع على الارض
وتحديد المواقع التي تتمركز فيها على وجه
الدقه حتى يقوم بعمليات عسكريه على الارض
حتى اللحظه هنالك تحليق للطائرات لكن لا
وجود للمضادات الطائرات في في الارض هنا
على ام درمان في جنوب صالحه وكذلك في
منطقه المهندسين والهيئه العامه للاذاعه
والتلفزيون علمنا ان هنالك مناوشات طفيفه
بالاسلحه الخفيفه وهنالك مدفعيه ثقيله من
سلاح المهندسين تنطلق من المهندسين ربما
هي لمراكز تتبع لقوات الدعم السريع
تستهدفها في مدينه بحري ومدينه الخرطوم
على العموم الوضع ميدانيا في المناطق
المحتدمه لا احد يستطيع الدخول اليها خاصه
منطقه سوق ام درمان ومنطقه منطقه عفوا
منطقه مستشفى ام درمان كان هنالك بحسب ما
علمنا ان هنالك انتشارا كثيفا للقوات
الدعم السريعه لهذه المنطقه ورشحت انباك
كثيره تقول ان قوات الدعم السريعه حاولت
ان تبسط سيطرتها بالكامل على هذه المنطقه
وسلاح الجو يحاول ان يمسح بطلعات جويه على
الارض الوضع الانسانيا يزداد صعوبه فقط
قبل وضع الانساني يعني عوده سؤالك في
الوضع الميداني فيما يتعلق بتواجد قوات
الدعم نعم تواي قوات الدعم السريعه
والتمركزاتها ايضا هل فقط هي في منطقه وسط
ام درمان او منطقه سوق ام درمان وجنوب ام
درمان ماذا عن المناطق الشماليه تحدث عن
الثورات نتحدث مثلا عن غرب ام درمان منطقه
ام بده وغيرها هل تتواجد فيها اشتباكات او
تمركزات القوات الدعم السريع ايضا
نعم منطقه شمال ام درمان منطقه الثوره
تحديدا لا وجود لاي تواجد عسكري من كلا
الجانبين لكن المنطقه الشماليه اقصى
المنطقه الشماليه منطقه معسكر كرري ومعسكر
جبل سركاب وكذلك الكليه الحربيه ومنطقه
وادي سيدنا هي منطقه تحت سيطره القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وكذلك جسر الحلفايه هذه
المناطق كانت تدور فيها معارك كثيفه في
الايام القليله الماضيه لكن حتى هذه
اللحظه لم ترد الينا ام اي انباع عن تواجد
للقوات الدعم السريع في المناطق الشماليه
اما بالنسبه للمناطق الغربيه ومنطقه جنوب
وغرب ام درمان هنالك تواجد لقوات الدعم
السريع في القوات الدعم السريع عفوا في في
منطقه غرب ام درمان تحديدا حتى يعني الجزء
الشرقي لسوق ليبيا اما منطقه سوق ليبيا
على وجه التحديد وكذلك منطقه سوق قندهار
او موقف قندهار الذي تنطلق منه الحافلات
السفريه باتجاه مصر لا وجود لي هذه الق
عسكريه في هذه المناطق اما منطقه سلاح
المهندسين والهيئه العامه للاذاعه
والتلفزيون فهي تدور فيها معارك مختلفه في
اوقات بين الفينه والاخرى وكذلك منطقه
جنوب ام درمان طيب الجيش السوداني تحدث
ايضا مقداد عن ان الدعم الذي ياتي لقوات
الدعم السريع والامدادات تاتي من جهه من
غربها من جهه غرب سنة تحديدا كيف تعامل
معها الجيش السوداني في خلال الساعات
الماضيه او الايام الماضيه
نعم الجيش السوداني كان قد اعلن في بيان
له انه تم رصد لارسال عسكريه تاتي من هذه
المناطق المناطق الغربيه خصوصا انها
محاذيه لولايه شمال دارفور وكذلك ولايه
شمال كردفان وتحديدا منطقه
كان الجيش السوداني قد رصد بحسب البيان
الذي يعني نزل بالامس ان هنالك ارتال
عسكريه تتبع لقوات الدعم السريع تتحرك نحو
منطقه غربيه ام درمان وعلى ما يبدو ان
الجيش السوداني يتعامل في هذه المنطقه عن
طريق سلاح الجو السوداني
لان اشهد يعني التحركات
كثيره في سماء ام درمان وعلى ما يبدو انه
يذهب الى تلك المناطق الغربيه التي تعتبر
مدخل لقوات الدعم السريع من الجهه الغربيه
لام درمان كنت بدات حديثا ايضا حول
الاوضاع الانسانيه في ام درمان يمكنك ان
تكمل يعني ما الذي يمكن ان تخبرنا به عن
ذلك
نعم بالنسبه للاوضاع الانسانيه كما استفدت
الذكرى ان الوضع يزداد صعوبه خصوصا وان
المواجهه تدخل اليوم العشرين وانقطاع تام
للوقود في مناطق ام درمان لا وجود لامداد
في محطات الوقود وكذلك امداد السلاسل
الغذائي يتحدثون ان مخزون الذي يتعامل به
يوميا هو المخزون الذي اصلا كان موجود قبل
هذه الاحداث وان كذلك
الحريق الذي في المنطقه الصناعيه بحري هو
سينعكس بلا شك على الاوضاع الغذائيه
والاوضاع الانسانيه في المصانع الغذائيه
وكذلك مصانع الادويه بحسب البيان الذي صدر
من غرفه المصنع الادويه ان هنالك نهب وحرق
لكثير من مصانع الادويه التي تعتبر مخزون
استراتيجي يمكن ان يغذي البلاد في المرحله
القادمه وكذلك في على الارض هنالك قذائف
تسقط هنا وهناك مما تزيد من يعني صعوبه
التنقل وكذلك صعوبه الحركه القريب كانت
هنالك
سقطت غذيفه في منطقه حي الشرفيه هنا في
شرقي الثورات او او في شرق كليه التربيه
جامعه الخرطوم تحديدا اودت بحياه طفله
وكذلك يعني خلفت جراحا كثيره في تلك
المنطقه وهذا وربما يعقد الوضع الانساني
والامني على المنطقه وعلى تحرك المواطنين
حتى في المناطق التي تعتبر امنيا يعني شبه
مستتبه فيها خلافا للمناطق التي تحتدم
فيها المناوشات في منطقه جنوب ووسط ام
درمان تلك المناطق يعني تختلف او تنعدم
فيها الحركه تماما كما تحدثنا الى الكثير
يقول ان هنالك ارتال عسكريه تنتشر داخل
الاحياء وان الحركه تبدو فيها شبه معدومه
وان كذلك سلاسل الامداد الغذائي والدوائي
وانقطاع الكهرباء والتيار المائي يمكن ان
يفاقم الاوضاع الانسانيه في تلك المناطق
بصوره اكثر من المنا
الشماليه والمناطق الغربيه التي تبدو فيها
الحياه شبه طبيعيه وان هناك حركه للماره
وحركه للاسواق وحركه كذلك
للمحاله التجاريه وايضا شاهدنا هنا لان
هنالك امدادا من الدقيق الذي ياتي من
المخازن التي مخازن مخازن والمطاحن لدقيق
القمح الذي يتواجد في منطقه شمال بحري
هنالك بعض المخازن هنالك بعض المخابز جاها
امداد امداد غذائي من هذه المصانع لكن
تواجه ايضا هذه المخابز مشكله اخرى وهي
انقطاع الغاز الذي يعني يمثل مشكله كبيره
بالنسبه لكثير من المخابز وان هنالك كثير
من المخابز قد اغلقت جراء هذا الانقطاع
وربما هنالك بديل اخر هو وقود الحطب الذي
يستخدم الان في في مخابز العاصمه او مخابز
شمال ام درمان تحديدا وضحت شكرا لك من
اندرمان كنت معنا الصح في مقداد حسن
تحياتي مقداد
اعرب الامين العام الاوم المتحده
لاخفاق المنظمه في وقف الحرب في السودان
حيث تقوض المعارك المستمره جهود ترسيخ
الهدنه وقال غوتيرشين الامم المتحده فوجئت
بتفجر العنف في السودان ولم تتوقع تطور
الاحداث بهذه السرعه وشدد غوتيريش على
الضروره التحرك بصفه مستعجله ووقف كافه
اشكال التصعيد وايجاد حل يعيد السودان الى
بر الامان والسعي الى تحقيق الاستقرار
والوحده
كشف الناطق باسم اللجنه التمهيديه لنقابه
اطباء السودان سيد محمد عبدالله عن توقف
اكثر من 67% من مستشفيات بل من المستشفيات
المتاخمه لمناطق الاشتباكات عن الخدمه
وشددا على ضروره اعاده تشكيل هذه
المستشفيات او تشغيل هذه المستشفيات
وايقاف الاشتباكات في اقرب وقت ممكن
ان هناك اكثر من 67% من المستشفيات في
مناطق النزاع متوقفه تماما عن الخدمه 89
من 88 مستشفى
يعمل منها فقط 29 بشكل بعضها بشكل جزئي
نحن نحرص على حياه الانسان نحاول مع لجعل
المقاومه مع المتطوعين ومع الزملائنا ان
نعيد التشغيل هذه المستشفيات ولكن
القتال المستمر والقصف العشوائي وكل هذه
الاشياء تمنع ذلك للاسف
الكادر محدود لعدم تمكنوا من الحركه
الكادر الطبي لا يستطيع المعينات الطبيه
في تناقص مستمر وحتى الكهرباء والمياه
يواصل مائه السودانيين نزوحهم نحو مصر
فارينا من المعارك المستمره بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع وفي الايام
الماضيه شهدت المعابر البريه الجنوبيه بين
مصر والسودان تزاحما شديدا لعبور عشرات
الحافلات التي تقل سودانيين والاجانب
المقيمين في البلاد الى مصر
ولنحن نشكر
على حسن الاداء والضيافه والمعامله ولكن
في بعض النواقص اشير اليها تكدس عالي جدا
ويحتاج الى خدمات اسرع الناس جايه بتنشن
عالي جدا بنك حاله بتاعه حرب رجاء
يعني مناوله ومداوله الامر باسرع في تقدس
كثير في حلفا هي دي المشكله حاسب بيتقابل
بيتقابل
يعني احتمروا عالقينهم العالقين بجمهوريه
يعني جمهوريه مصر العربيه هم قاعدين نحسب
حلفا يعني شغال من السودان برفع مواطنين
من المعبره للسوداني لابو سمبل
يعني صعبه يعني مال الحروبات والمشاكل
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا الكاتب الصحفي محمد
شمس الدين اهلا بك يا سيد محمد معنا في
هذه الساعه الاخباريه وهل يمكن حديث وفق
المعطيات الحاليه عن تضاؤل الاعمال حول
العثور او التوصل الى حل سلمي ينهي هذه
الازمه ام ان المقاربه العسكريه الخيار
الاوحد الاول لكلى الطرفين
تحياتي لك يا اخي احمد المشاهدين يعني هذا
الخيار العسكري الذي هو الخيار المفضل حتى
هذه اللحظه على ما يبدو قائمه على قدم
وساق وهناك من يرى بان هذا الامر مرتبط
ربما
بالخيارات التي يعني سيوضع امام
يوضع امامها الطرفان مساله التفاوض
واللجوء الى الخيار السلمي ايضا هو في
المنظور القريب ولكن هناك بعض المتطلبات
الميدانيه بحسب ما يرى او ما ترى المؤسسه
العسكريه في ذلك عبر تصريحاتها بطبيعه
الحال هناك من يقول بان هذه العمليات
التصحينيه في هذه الاوقات ربما تكون بهدف
ايجاد يعني وضع قوي فيما يتعلق بالسقوف
التفاوضيه
تكثيف في العمليات في الفتره
المؤخره في ثلاثه ايام الاخيره
كان ملحوظ ومساربا التوقيت لكن على الجانب
الاخر الدعوات لم تتوقف باتجاه تحول نحو
الخيار الاساسي هناك جبهه عريضه تشكلت وما
زالت التوقيعات تجمع حولها فيما يتعلق
بضروره
وقف اطلاق النار ومناهضه الحرب ويعني
ايقاف نزيف الدماغ بطبيعه الحال هناك حلول
ايضا يقول الجيش بانه
يعني يقبل بها ولكنها قد لا تكون في صالح
الطرف الاخر
وكلها بتتركز في عمليه استسلام من طرف
الاخر بطبيعه الحال الجيش يقول بانه لن
يقبل سوى بمحاكمه
القيادات الطرف الاخر وايضا يعرض العفو
العام على عناصر الدعم السريع شوفت ايضا
لقطات على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي في هذا
الخصوص تظهر تسريحه اعداد من
الاحزاب السياسيه مثلا او عن حتى عن
الادارات الاهليه والمجتمعيه ام انها هي
اصلا جزء منها من هذه الازمه
صحيح يعني كثير من القراءات تشير الى ان
المشهد السياسي الذي تازم مؤخرا كان جزءا
من مشهد التصعيد اليوم
التصريحات
المتضاربه وكذلك حاله التعنت والانسداد
السياسي الذي كان سائدا في الفتره الماضيه
يعني كثير من المراقبين قالوا بان ذلك
ربما كان احد الاسباب الرئيسيه في اندلاع
هذه المواجهات والتي وصفت من قبل كثيرين
ايضا
معارك مؤجله كانت هذه المعركه حتميه
ومنتظره وارهاصتها يعني ظاهره للعيان
الجميع شاهد كيف يتم او كانت تتم عمليات
التحشيد واستجلاب القوات من الطرفين الى
داخل العاصمه وكانت تظهر تفسيرات
وضعت جميعها في اطار يعني المراوغه او
الحرب النفسيه في الفتره الماضيه
يعني لم تخب تلك التوقعات من كثيرين هذه
المساله بطبيعه الحال وجهت بكثير من الرفض
او برفض شعبي كبير جدا مساله اندلاع الحرب
لكن وبعد اندلعت الحرب ايضا
يعني شاهدنا كيف انقسم المجتمع السوداني
ما بين يعني مؤيد لهذه الحرب
العسكري ولكن سؤالي كان حول الجانب
السياسي لهذه الازمه وسؤالي هنا ايضا يعني
ان هذه الازمه هل تعتقد ان النخبه
السياسيه بناء على هذه الازمه هل على
النخبه السياسيه اعاده النظر في وضع
المكونات السياسيه الحاليه وتغيير ايضا
منهج التفكير القائم في العقليه
السياسيه السودانيه وبالتالي ربما خلق
عمليه سياسيه جديده تعتمد على مفاهيم
جديده في خارطه المشهد السياسي السوداني
تماما هذا هو رايي الغالبيه في المجتمع
السوداني اليوم الذين نتحدث معهم كلهم
يقولون بانه هذه المرحله المنصمه من
العمليه السياسيه لم تعد صالحه لوضع
الراحل ولا للوضع المستقبلي ما زالت حديث
كثير من السياسيين تنصب حول ضروره يعني
اعاده احياء العمليه السياسيه
والبدء من النقطه التي توقفت عندها
السياسيه ويبنون هذه الافتراضات وشكرا
الاحتمالات
يعني اتصالاتهم او مدى قوه اتصالاتهم
باطراف الصراع اليوم
فيه كثيرون انا مطر لمقاطعتك هنا من
الخرطوم كنت معا اذا الكاتب الصحفي محمد
شمس الدين شكرا لكم محمد
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات